منذ صيف هذا العام خمسه اجتماعات لوزراء
الطاقه الاوروبيين في محاوله الاتفاق على
اليه لوضع السقف لاسعار الغاز بعد فشل في
توافق خلال الشهور الماضيه تقليل اسعار
الكهرباء هدف واحد والوصول اليه لا يبدو
عبر طريق واحد في ظل ارتفاع اسعار الغاز
مع خفض روسيا لشحناتها نحو اوروبا في اعقب
حربها على اوكرانيا يهدد الانقسام
الاوروبي بعرقله اتفاقات المبدايه سابقه
تتعلق بشراء الغاز بصوره جماعيه للحصول
معا على اسعار افضل ووجود اليه تضامن تؤمن
تلقائيا للدول المهدده بازمه طاقه اما
الاتفاق الثاني فيبسط ويسرعوا اليه مدح
التراخيص لاقامه المتجدده
تقترح المفوضيه الاوروبيه بان تشغل اليه
السقف الاسعار تلقائيه بمجرد تجاوز
الاسعار عتبه المئتين 275 يورو للميجاوات
السعي لمده اسبوعين متتاليين بينما ترغب
12 دوله اوروبيه بخفضه الى ما دون ذلك
بشكل كبير وهي كل من بلجيكا وبلغاريا
وكرواتيا واليونان وايطاليا و ليتوانيا و
بولندا ورومانيا
واسبانيا واليونان بما اعتبرته استهزاءا
مطالبه بتلين الشروط المطلوبه في المقابل
طلبت عده دول المصحفظه على اي تدخل بينها
المانيا وهولندا والنمسا بوضع حذر بالغه
الشده لمنع اي سقف قد يفعل من تهديد
امدادات الغزل اوروبا وبعض المزودين
الاساسيين مثل النرويج يتخوفون من سقف
يوضع بشكل وق يشجعوا بعض المزودين على
التخلي عن اوروبا لصالح زبائن اسيويين
يدفعون اسعارا افضل ويرى البنك المركزي
الاوروبي ان فرض السقف غير مدروس قد يزيد
من التقلبات ويعرض للخطر الاستقرار
الماليه في منطق اليوم وضع دفع مفوضه
لاتحاد الاوروبي لشؤون الطاقه الى القول
ان الاراء والمخاوف متباينه جدا داعيه
للجميع الى ابداء مرونه اكبر بينما
الشدادات وزيره الطاقه الفرنسيه على
الحاجه الى تامين امدادات الغاز وحمايه
المؤسسات والافراد واستقرار الاسواق
الماليه اما رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
فاعتبر التنازع عدد من الدول الاعضاء على
اسعار بيع وشراء الغاز امرا غير مقبول
مشيرتان الى ان الشتاء المقبل سيشكل تحديا
اكبر خلافه الغاز وسقف اسعاره لا تبعد
عنها خلافات سابقا بشان وضع السقف لسعر
الروسي واخرى بشان العقوبه على روسيا التي
تبدا اوروبا متباينه بشانها ايضا